(cheerful jazzy music)
(clapping)
(Evan and woman exclaiming)
(Evan laughs)
(bleeping)
(Danny burps)
(everyone exclaiming in surprise)
(Danny cries out)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Are you serious?
(Danny and woman yell)
(speaking in foreign language)
(woman laughing)
- You know like, how
there's like the black hole
and like, on the other side of it,
there's like the white hole.
I think if you go in
there, you see aliens.
Do you think they'll
like, take me as a family?
That's a big thing to think
about by the way, you guys.
Shots to that, that's sick!
(speaking in foreign language)
- Let's go, I'm tired.
- Let's go, let's go, let's
go.
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, wait, I want
more, let's drink more.
- More?
- Order more, I'm gonna...
- Let's go, let's go (mumbles).
We have to go.
- No, no, no, no, no.
We just came out, let's go to my house.
I have a minibar at my house.
- Ooh, you have a minibar?
- Don't be lame, okay?
Don't be a party pooper right now, Evan.
- [Together] Yay!
(throat hawking)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Hey guys, we're--
- Pero Like!
- Did you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
(speaks in foreign language)
- For more Latino content--
- Subscribe here!